[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance I did not write what follows
but it is perfect so I will read it as
it was written and then I will give you
the backstory afterwards we cannot have
a country led by a president subject to
ongoing criminal investigations
potential indictments and never-ending
hearings we cannot have a president
under that level of scrutiny that
inevitably leads to even more questions
and more investigations and irrespective
of what happens to him whether he's
indicted or even guilty it doesn't
matter
his guilt is a moot point he cannot take
the Oval Office
now in any other business when the head
of a corporation is plagued by scandal
that person steps down and is replaced
because the board knows that a business
cannot succeed without respect and
authority how do you think the world is
going to look at the United States when
a man under federal criminal
investigation who's lied repeatedly to
the American people is elected do you
think they'll take him at his word that
was written and presented by Jeanine
Pirro on her show on the Fox News
Channel on Saturday November 5th 2016 it
was her final argument for why you could
not vote for Hillary Clinton and must
instead vote for Donald Trump we cannot
have a president under that level of
scrutiny whether indicted or even guilty
it doesn't matter
guilt is a moot point I changed all the
Xi's to he's ain't IA stinker resist
remove piece